اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
موسكو وكيف تتبادلان الاتهامات بشان
المسؤوليه عن تفجير سد نوفا خوفكا يدعو
العالم للتحرك
وتوقعاتهم بانخفاض مخزون مياه التبريد
بمحطه زفروجيا النوويه لسبعه امتار وخرسون
تغرق
الخارجيه الامريكيه تجدد التزامها بتعزيز
الشراكه الامنيه مع السعوديه وبلانكن يبحث
التعاون الاستراتيجي بين البلدين
مظاهرات عارمه في باريس ضد قانون التقاعد
والسلطات الفرنسيه تنشر ما لا يقل عن احد
عشر الفرد من قوات الشرطه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
خرسون تغرق تحت المياه والمخاوف تتزايد
حول محطه النوويه ودعوات للعالم الى
التدخل هذا هو واقع الحال بعد تفجير سد
نوبكا خوفكا الاستراتيجي
جديد التطورات هو اعلان حاكم خرسون
الموالي لروسيا فلاديمير سالدو انه لا
يمكن السيطره على تدفق مياه السد متهما
اوكرانيا بقصف السد بصواريخ ستورم شادو
البريطانيه ما ادى الى تدميره
وزير الداخليه الاوكرانيه ايغور كليمنكو
وقال من جهته ان الفيضانات اجتاحت 24 بلده
بعد الهجوم مشيرا الى انه تم اجلاء حوالي
الف مدني من المنطقه وانا وان عمليه
الاجلاء مستمره
في مقابل ذلك اعنت السلطات الاوكرانيه عن
وجود تسريبات زيوت محركات اثر انفجار سيد
نوفا حيث قالت مستشاره مدير مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني داريا زريفنا ان 150 طنا من زيت
المحركات تسربت الى نهر دينيبرو بعد
انفجار السد مضيحه ان هناك المزيد من
الاخطار جراء حدوثه تسربات اخرى تؤثر سلبا
على البيئه ومضيفه ان هدف الروس من تفجير
السد هو ضرب القطاع الزراعي الاوكراني
وازاحه اوكرانيا كمنافس وابتزاز العالم
بازمات الجوع
استهدافه سد نوبك اخوفكا تسبب بارتفاع
منسوب مياهنا كما ذكرنا وانخفاض مياه
مخزونات السد بعد توقف اربعه توربينات وقد
دعت السلطات في خرسون السكان في الاجزاء
المنخفضه من المدينه الى اخلاء مساكنهم
باسرع وقت ممكن والبحث عن ماوى على اراضي
مرتفعه بسبب الفيضانات وقالت السلطات هناك
ان 16 الف شخص ما زالوا يقطنون فيما اسمته
بالمنطقه الحرجه
وعلى بعد 100 ميل في الشمال الشرقي تقع
محطه ذابروجيا النوويه التي تعتمد على
مخزونات المياه من سد نوبكا خوفك في عمليه
التبريد اللازمه لمنع كارثه نوويه كما
يعتبر السد قناه حيويه لنقل المياه من نهر
دنيبرو الى شبه جزيره القرم حيث اكد
مسؤولون ان المناطق الشماليه مهدده بالعطش
لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم اليه من الان
الصحفي محمد البابا محمد اهلا وسهلا بك
اخر المعلومات محمد المتصله بتفجير سد سد
كفوفكا والى اي مدى المساله خطيره وخطيره
جدا على السكان وكذلك على محطه النوويه
نعم يعني بالبدايه طريقه التفجير كما
يتداول في وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من خلال وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه انه تم ضمن تفجيرات
وليس باستهداف صاروخي الجانب الاوكراني
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه نفد ان تكون قد
قامت باي ضربات صاروخيه في ساعات الليل
لانه في تلك الوقت يعني وقت ما حصل
التفجير كانت اوكرانيا تتعرض لضربات
صاروخيه وكان هدف القوات الاوكرانيه
الصواريخ الروسيه التي اطلقت باتجاه عدد
من المدن الاوكرانيه ومنها العاصمه
الاوكرانيه المساله الثانيه هو كما يتداول
ايضا مساله التلوث البيئي بفعل عندما تم
يعني تفجير داخل محطه محطه الكهرومائيه في
محطه
تسربت كميات كبيره من الزيوت توازي 150 طن
انتشرت مع المياه وانتشرت في السهول
والاحياء والكره هناك حتى هذه اللحظه سبع
او الكره غمرت بالكامل من الجهه يعني
الغربيه لنهر جنيفر والمياه لا تزال تتدفق
حتى هذه اللحظه كما يتداول بحسب السلطات
المحليه في مقاطعه زاكا حوالي 20% من
المياه التي كانت محتجزه بسبب السد قد
تدفقت وبكميات كبيره ويستمر التدفق ولا
يمكن السيطره الان على هذه يعني هذا السد
بعد تدمير الاجزاء الكبرى حوالي 80% من
السد قد تم تدميره او من
11 يعني حائط خرساني تدمر بفعل هذا
التبشير والذي كما يتداول لا يمكن لصاروخ
هايمرز او كما يتداول ام محمد يعني محمد
يعني المسؤولون الروس يؤكدون ان كيف ان
الجيش الاوكراني هو من ضرب هذا السد
بصواريخ حتى يعني يحددون الصواريخ ستورم
شادو البريطانيه طيب لماذا هذا جانبا
سنناقشه مع ساناقشه
بعد قليل من روسيا ومن من موسكو من طيب
محمد ماذا عن باقي الجبهات الاخرى وساحات
القتال المفتوحه يعني وزير الدفاع الروسي
سرق شويغو اكد اليوم ان الجيش الاوكراني
حاول التقدم في سبعه محاور لكنه فشل تماما
كيف هي المعلومات الاوكرانيه بحسب وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه وغرفه العمليات
المشتركه فكره تقول ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقوم بعده يعني هجومات ناجحه حتى هذه
اللحظه ولا بشكل بطيء في محيط مدينه
باكموت في محور ليمان وكريمينيا القوات
الاوكرانيه تتقدم ولكن بشكل بطيء جدا
اضافه الى التطور العسكري المستمر في
منطقه حيث ان فيلق يعني
الحره يقوم بعمليات في بعض الكره الحدوديه
يعني وتمتد المساحه الجغرافيه التي سيطر
عليها خاصه يعني نشر قبل حوالي ثلاثه
ساعات هذا فايلق فايلق يعني المتطوعين
الروس وروسيا الحره الفيديو من اعتقالهم
واسرهم لعدد من الجنود الروسي حيث يتداول
ان هناك العشرات من الجنود الروس اصبحوا
بقبضه هذه المجموعه في مدينه باخمت ومحيط
باخموت القوات الاوكرانيه تستمر بتقدمها
في المنطقه الشماليه ويتداول ان معظم
المنطقه الشماليه لمدينه
القوات الاوكرانيه بعد تراجع الجيش الروسي
من تلك المنطقه بفعل الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه لا تعطي
تفاصيل دقيقه عن الهجوم المضاد بحسب
الاستراتيجيه التي تتبعها وتقول ان الشعب
الاوكراني سيرى النتائج على الارض وتحس
يعني تحس وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه في اكثر
من بيان وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه بعدم
التداول بما تبثه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من
اخبار يعني تشويه سمعه الهجوم المضاد
وضربه قبل ان يحقق اهدافه الجيش الاوكراني
يعني هن مليار قالت ان احد اسباب تفجير
الاسد هو منع الهجوم المضاد في الجهه
الجنوبيه لاوكرانيا وتركيز العمليات في
الجهه يعني الشرقيه والشماليه لمقاطعه
الصحفي محمد البابا محمد شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين لماذا تمت مهاجمه سد
نوفا ومن قام بذلك يتبادل الطرفان
الاوكراني والروسي التهم حول من فجر السبت
الجيش الاوكراني يتهم روسيا بتعمد تفجيره
في وقت مبكر من صباح اليوم
وبحسب محللين قد يكونوا هذا ممكنا حيث
تخشى موسكو من ان تستخدم القوات
الاوكرانيه الطريقه فوق السد لنقل قواتها
عبر النهر الى الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا كجزء من هجوم مضاد وبالتالي تم
تفجيره من قبلهم روسيا بدورها القت باللوم
على اوكرانيا بقصف السد مضيحه ان الجزء
العلوي من السد دمر بالكامل بسبب القصف
وليس السد نفسه
والهدف بحسب موسكو هو قطع المياه عن جزيره
القرم حيث ينخفض منسوب المياه وبالتالي
تنخفض امدادات المياه الى القناه بشكل حاد
واضافه الى ذلك ترى روسيا ان من اسباب
تفجير اوكرانيا للسد ايضا هو تدمير محطه
كخوفكا للطاقه الكهرومائيه
السفير الروسي لدى فيينا ميخائيل اليانوف
وفي مقابله مع العربيه استبعت تورط بلاده
بحادثه قصف السد مشددا على اهتمام روسيا
بسلامه وامن منشاه النوويه
انا واثق من ان روسيا لم تقصف السد في
الواقع اوكرانيا ومنذ الصيف الماضي تقصفه
ولكن نحن لا نحتاج للقيام بمثل هذه
العمليات نحن نهتم بالمنشاه النوويه التي
تقع تحت سيطرتنا ولكن الاوكرانيين يصرون
على ان الروس دائما يقصفون انفسهم
اما الامير العام لحلف الناتو يانسوس فقد
حذر من ان تدمير سيد نوبكا خوفكا في جنوب
اوكرانيا يعرض الاف المدنيين للخطر ووصف
الصولنبر استهداف السد بانه عمل شائن
ويثبت مجددا وحشيه الهجوم الروسي حسب
تعبيره
لقد غيرت الحرب العدوانيه غير المبرره
التي تشنها روسيا ضد اوكرانيا بئتنا
الامنيه على المدى الطويل لقد مزقت روسيا
السلام في اوروبا واليوم يعارض تدمير سد
كخوفكا الاف المدنيين للخطر ويتسبب في
اضرار بيئيه جسيمه هذا عمل مشين ويظهر مره
اخرى وحشيه الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
منظومه صاروخيه اوكرانيه
مصنفه ضمن المنظومات الثقيله اليه الاطلاق
تحمل صواريخ موجهه تم تصميمها لضرب اهداف
متنوعه
الصاروخ يعمل بالوقود الصلب يحتوي على
نظام توجيه ذاتي مدى الصاروخ 70 كم
دخل الخدمه في القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
عام 2019
استلمت القوات الاوكرانيه اكثر من 90
صاروخا من هذا الصنف روسيا تتهم اوكرانيا
باستخدام منظومه اورفا في استهداف سد
نوفاكا
اوكرانيا اتهمت القوات الروسيه بتفجير
السد لابطاء تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه
باغراق منطقه خرسون
على كل لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل ينضم
الي من كييف الان ماكسيميالي وهو استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه الطيران
الوطنيه في كيف ومن موسكو ينضم الي المحلل
السياسي
اهلا وسهلا بك كما يقال دائما في الحروب
تكون الحقيقه هي اول الضحايا هل لدى موسكو
ادله دامغه تثبت ان هي المتورطه في تفجير
وتدمير هذا السد واذا كان لدي هذه الادله
لماذا لا تنشره على الملا
لا توجد لدينا ادله وكمان لا توجد حاليا
ادله الجنب الاوكراني بان روسيا متوارثه
في ذلك ولكن كما تفضلتم ان الحقيقه هي
تحليل الاولى في الحروب وفي هذا الدعاء
اعتقد يجب ان نفكر
من هو المستفيد من مما حدث في مع هذا
الساده نتيجه تدمير هذا الصعد فيمكن ان
اقول جزئيا تستفيدنا بكل صراحه جزئيا
تستفيد من ذلك روسيا جزئيا تستفيد من ذلك
اوكرانيا
طبعا
على مارس سيكون هناك تاجيل لما يسمى
بالهجوم المضاد الاوكراني هذا لروسيا مزيد
من وقت لتحضير مثل هذا الهجوم المضاد ولكن
خلاص هذا هذه الاستفاده الروسيه تنتهي مع
ذلك بين المصالح الاوكرانيه مع تفجير هذا
بكثير اولا هذا يسمح لاوكرانيا ان تطاهم
روسيا وتواجه الاتهامات ضروسي يعني انشاء
هذه الكارثه
ونحن نعلم الدول الغربيه فعلا تحترم
بالمساله الكولاجيه وما هنالك كذلك تزداد
لمخاطر حول يعني كارثه في محطه زباروجي
بسبب
ونحن نعلم ان روسيا تسيطر على هذه المرحله
محطه
النوويه طبعا كذلك هذا بالنسبه
يعني تدمير هذا يعطي مزيد من الوقت من
جديد لتاجيل ما يسمى بالهجوم المضاد بسبب
ان ليس سيرا اننا توجد هناك دخولات من قبل
الدول الغربيه على اوكرانيا لكي تبدا هذا
الهجوم المضارع هنالك اضافه اضافه ان
اراده التي اصبحت تحت المياه حاليا هي
اراضي بشكل عام تحت السيطره روسيا
انا اعتقد ان يجب ان نقارن بين المصالح
الاوكرانيه ومصالح الفيروسيه نتيجه
لاسمع السيد مكسيميالي سيد مكسيم السؤال
ايضا موجه لالك السيد يقول انه المصلحه
الاوكرانيه بتفجير السد اكبر بكثير من
المصلحه الروسيه خصوصا وان المناطق التي
غمرتها المياه هي مناطق خاضعه للسيطره
الروسيه كما محطه وانه شبه جزيره القرم
ستعاني من العطش فبالتالي المصلحه
الاوكرانيه اكبر بكثير في تفجير السد من
المصلحه الروسيه وهنا السؤال اذا كانت
اكياف متاكده ان موسكو هي من قامت بهذا
التفجير لماذا لا تنشر الادله على الملا
لماذا فقط الاتهام
اسعدتم مساء
ساقدم لك بعض الحقائق
التي
ليست بحاجه الى دله اولا القوات
الاوكرانيه
ليست لديها الامكانات لتفجيري هذا السد
لانه كبير جدا
روسيا هي التي تسيطر على هذه المنطقه كما
قلتم
منذ اكتوبر الماضي
قال في اكتوبر
صحيح المنطقه تحت السيطره الروس
ولكن من هو المستفيد
الان من المستحيل
كما نعرف لا يبالون بمواطنهم
كما شاهدنا على مدى التاريخ
عندما ضرب
منظومه الطاقه
كبيره جدا لاوكرانيا لان هذا ستغرق مناطقه
واسعه
لانقل سؤال الى السيدوس ايا يكن ايا تكن
الجهه التي تقف وراء هذا الهجوم ان يستهدف
هذا السد الاستراتيجي بهذا الشكل يعني ان
الحرب دخلت مرحله خطره وخطيره جدا وبدات
ضرب من تحت الحزام ان صح التعبير سؤال اي
مرحله دخلتها الحرب بعد تفجير هذا السد
وما الذي سنشاهده في الايام المقبله
ربما انا سافاجئكم بجوابه ولكن وفقا لما
اتبيعه في المناقشات في داخل روسيا هناك
فرق في الاراء البعض يقول بان مثل هذه
الكارثه
قد يؤدي الى تجميد القتاليه على الاقل
بشكل مؤقت بين روسيا والاوكرانيا مثل هذه
الاراء موجوده حاليا في روسيا ولكن طبعا
البعض بالعكس يفكر بان
بان ما حدث مع هذا السد فطبعا سيشجع الدول
الغربيه لتسارع في تسليم الاسلحه الجديده
قبل كل شيء الطائرات 16 الى اوكرانيا كذلك
الصواريخ بعيد الماده لا يوجد هناك رؤيه
الموحده في في روسيا على هذا الشان انا
شخصيا
اعتقد ان نحن مزيد من التصعيد بسبب ان من
جديد اقول يعني هذا ما حدث هذا تفجير
للسادسه يعطي لسلطات الاوكرانيه فرصه
ممتازه لتوجيها الاتهامات لروسيا بانها
تقف وراء الكارثه الايكولوجيه بان هي يمكن
ان هذه الكارثه يمكن ان تؤدي حتى الكارثه
النوويه باسباب التي ذكرتها سابق متعلقه
به يعني مخاطر المزداد او ازدياد المخاطر
حول المحطه النوويه والى ما هنالك اي نحن
نعلم الدول الغربيه تحترم كثيرا بالمسائل
الايكولوجيه مسائل النوويه فهذه الورقه
قويه حاليا في ايدي اوكرانيا
نحن نعود الى سؤال بسيط من يستفيد اكثر من
ذلك
في النقاش من موسكو اندري انتيكوفا المحلل
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
شكرا ايضا
لمكسيميا الاستاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه الطيران الوطنيه كان معي
[موسيقى]
الى هذا المؤتمر الصحفي لامين عام حلف
انيته
ك صارخ للقانون الدولي
حلفانات المختلفين وهذا الشيء قلنا فيما
تكرار
وهو جزء من
اما اتفقنا عليه مع كافه حلفائنا من اجل
اخطار
هذه نشاطات شفافه
الدوليه وبالتاكيد ان توم موجوده لحمايه
الديمقراطيه
وحمايه الحريه والانفتاح
الا تدخل ابدا في المسائل السياسيه
والمحليه
في حقوق الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
نكتفي بهذا القدر من هذا المؤتمر
الصحفية قال مدير عمل وكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافاء الدروسي انه ليس هناك
خطر نووي في محطه حتى الان نتيجه لتفجير
سد سد نوفا مؤكدا متابعته خبراء الوكاله
الموجودين في الموقع لهذا الوضع عن كثب
تقييمنا الحالي هو انه لا يوجد خطر مباشر
على السلامه المصنع نتابع هذا كل دقيقه تم
ابلاغ موظفي الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الضاريه بالموقع بان الاضرار التي لحقت
بالسد نوفاكا تؤدي حاليا الى انخفاض يصل
الى خمسه سنتيمترات في الساعه في ارتفاع
الخزان يواصل الفريق مراقبت هذا المعدل
وجميع الامور الاخرى على الموقع
معي من القاهره لمزيد من المتابعه الدكتور
علي عبد النبي وهو نائب رئيس هيئه المحطات
النوويه سابقا دكتور علي اهلا وسهلا بك ما
الذي يعنيه اهلا تحياتي ما الذي يعنيه
تفجير هذا السد على المستوى اولا البيئي
على المستوى الزراعي لانه يروي اراضي خصبه
تنتج محاصيل كبيره من الحبوب والاهم ما
الذي يعنيه على المستوى النووي لانه يبرد
المفاعلات النوويه لمحطه زفروجيا النووي
يعني
المستوى الزراعي
معروف انه اوكرانيا يعني اراضي زراعيه
وتوفر القمح لدول كثيره منها افريقيا
ومنها في اوروبا
وكمان هيبقى في كارثه بيئيه مش يعني هيبقى
في كارثه زراعيه نتيجه لان المياه هتقل
خالص للزراعه
وهيبقى في كارثه بيئيه نتيجه هيبقى فيه
مستنقعات وفي هيبدا بقى يتكون تتكرر
الحشرات والحاجات دي كلها وهيبقى في كارثه
بيئيه
دي من ناحيه الزراعه والبيئه يعني في
كارثه بيئيه على كارثه زراعيه دلوقتي
هياثروا على اوكرانيا بشكرانيا بس وعلى
الدول تستورد من اوكرانيا الحبوب زي القمح
والمواد الغذائيه
دي من ناحيه من الناحيه النوويه احنا السد
اللي هو
موجود دلوقتي السد ده
يعني هو في الجنوب
شماله محطه
اللي هي النوويه
الاوكرانيه فيها ست مفاعلات نوويه
المفاعلات دي المفاعلات من روسيا ار نوع
في 320
قدره المفاعله الواحد سته جيجا يعني
واحد جيجا متاسف واحد جيجا يعني المحطه
كلها الموقع
النووي في سته جيجا طيب
لو الخزان الميه اللي هو بتعتمد عليه محطه
النوويه في تبريد الوقود النووي سواء
الوقود النووي دخل مفعل او الوقود النووي
اللي هو موجود في احواض التبريد اللي هو
المستهلك يعني
اللي هو خرج من المفاعل ده عاوز تبريد
مستمر له المياه التبريد انقطعت يبقى
حيبقى في كارثه نوويه هو حتى الان معدل
التفريغ او معدل
انصراف الميه من الخزان حوالي 5 سم في
الساعه احنا معدل بسيط لان هو جسم السد
نفسه ما حصلوش تدمير اللي حصل تدمير حتى
اللي فوق الدكتور علي دكتور علي كيف يمكن
التقليل والتخفيف من الاضرار ام ان اي
اجراء الان هو اجراء متاخر صح التعبير
تمام يعني اولا لازم يتم تهجير التهجير او
يعملوا
للناس اللي هم هيحصل لهم ضرر من الفيضانات
الفيضان اللي هيطلع من الخزان المياه
لازم يحصل تهجير للناس دي الاول ثم يتم
خبراء الوكاله مع المشغلين للمحطه النوويه
يتم توفير بديل كهربائي
كهربي خارجي عشان يشغل التبريد في حاله
انقطاع مياه تبريد طب هيشغلوا ازاي يبقى
لازم يبقى فيه مياه تبريد خارجيه مع شبكه
الكهرباء خارجيه مياه تبريد لان في تيازل
ديزل تبريد لما بتنقطع الكهرباء الخارجيه
بتشتغل الديزل
بتشتغل بت
تبريد
اضافه الى كهرباء
لازم
طيب دكتور علي بعتقد دكتور علي بيعتقد
وصلت الفكره من القاهره الدكتور علي عبد
النبي نائب رئيس هيئه المحطات النوويه
سابقا شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
تجري كل من الصين والولايات المتحده كلا
على حدا مناورات عسكريه بحريه في منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ قد تدفع لتصعيد خطير
المزيد في التقرير التالي
للمره السادسه منذ عام 2019 الصين وروسيا
تنفذان دوريه جويه مشتركه فوق بحر اليابان
وبحر الصين الشرقي حيث تشارك سفن اسطول
الدولتين في تدريبات كومودو 2023 قباله
السواحل الاندونيسيه هذه الدوريه تزامنت
مع زياده الولايات المتحده مناوراتها
العسكريه مع حلفائها في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ حيث نفذت اول مناوره
ثلاثيه مشتركه باكثر من 500 من حرس
السواحل من امريكا والفلبين واليابان في
بحر الصين الجنوبي
الاستفزازات العسكريه بين الصين وامريكا
ليست بالجديده لكنها احتدت مؤخرا اسبوع
كامل من الاستعراضات العسكريه اشعل فتيل
الاتهامات بينهما في اواخر ماي الماضي
حادثه شهدتها مياه بحر الصين الجنوبي بين
طائره مقاتله صينيه وطائره استطلاع عسكريه
امريكيه وصفتها الخارجيه الصينيه
بالمناوره الاستفزازيه والخطيره تلتها
مناورات عسكريه صينيه مقابل بعدها بايام
كادت ان تتسبب بحادثه تصادم مع القوات
الامريكيه بحرا وجوا وصفها البيت الابيض
انذاك بانها عدوانيه المشهد المتوتر انعكس
على جانب اخر بين الصين وجارتها كوريا
الجنوبيه حيث نددت سول بقيام اربع مقاتلات
صينيه واربع روسيه باختراق منطقه الدفاع
الجوي الكوري دون انذار الامر الذي دفع
القوات الجويه الكوريه الجنوبيه لارسال
مقاتلاتها الى موقع الحادث التدريبات
العسكريه تاتي بعد اختتام مؤتمر شانجريلا
الامني في سنغافوره الذي شهد تبادل كبار
المسؤولين الامريكيين والصينيين
الانتقادات حول قضايا من بينها تايوان
وبحر الصين الجنوبي
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
تحذير اممي من خطوره الوضع في السودان على
المدنيين وعدد النازحين في دارفور يتجاوز
المليون
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
التزامه واشنطن بتعزيز شراكتها الامنيه مع
السعوديه بما في ذلك المبيعات الدفاعيه
والتدريبات المشتركه ومكافحه انتشار
الصواريخ والطيران المسير لدى جهات غير
حكوميه وقالت الوزاره في بيان حول
العلاقات بين واشنطن والرياض قبيل زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن الى
المملكه قالت ان التعاون مع السعوديه من
اجل ضمان الاستقرار الاقليمي يظل احدى
ركائز علاقاتنا الثنائيه
واضافت ان الشراكه الامنيه بين البلدين
قائمه على الاهتمام المشترك بامن منطقه
الخليج ومنع اي قوه اجنبيه او اقليميه من
تهديد المنطقه
هذا ويصل اليوم الى السعوديه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن لبحث
التعاون الاستراتيجي الامريكي السعودي في
القضايا الاقليميه والعالميه ومجموعه من
القضايا الثنائيه بما في ذلك التعاون
الاقتصادي والامري وافاد مراسل العربيه ان
زياره بلينكل للسعوديه ستستغرق يومين حيث
سيشارك في اجتماع وزري لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي الامريكي كما سيحضر بلنكن مع وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
اجتماعا وزاريا للتحالف الدولي بهزيمه
داعش في الرياض لتسطيط الضوء على الدوري
الحاسم الذي يلعبه التحالف لمواجهه
التهديد المستمر لداعش
عبر المفوض الاممي للاجئين في
الصدمه جراء تقارير افادت بمقتل عشره
لاجئين على الاقل في هجوم في الخرطوم
واعتبر المفوض الاممي للاجئين ان كل
المدنيين في السودان في خطر محدق حسب قوله
وفي اقليم دارفور يعيش الناس اوضاعا
ماساويه بسبب القتال الدائري في السودان
فقد شهدت عده مدن بالاقليم نزوحا وتشردا
كبيرا الى جانب نزوح عدد كبير الى الدول
المجاوره الامر الذي دفع حاكم الاقليم
منوي الى اعلان دارفور منطقه منكوبه تحتاج
الى المساعدات بعد اكثر من خمسين يوما من
القتال في السودان لحقت باقليم دارفور
اضرار عديده تمثلت في اللجوء والتشريد
لعدد كبير من المواطنين بهذا الغليم حاكم
اقليم دارفور مني اركب الناوي اعلن بان
اقليم دارفور يحتاج لمساعدات عاجله وبان
هذه المنطقه من السودان تعتبر منطقه
منكوبه لذلك تحتاج الى التدخلات العاجله
في اقرب وقت
والله بنطالب المنظمات الانسانيه والخيريه
انها تجينا راجع زي ما قالوا تقدمت العون
لانه في ناس عانت بجد بذاتي موزم الخريف
ده ونحن وبالوف عندنا في شهر 9 وشهر خمسه
واربعه والفصول والغريب دي يعني في بكون
ركود اقتصادي صعب جدا يعني المنظمات دي
بتسهل مساهمه كبيره لو جاءتوا بتساعد في
هالمشاكل كثير من البيوت يعني والله
القتال هو داير بين الجيش والدعم السريع
خلف نزوحا كبيرا با دارفور فقد تضررت
مراكز ايواء خاصه بالنازحين بغرب دارفور
تضرر معسكر نيفاشا وكساب بشمال دارفور
كمناطق يصعب ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
اليها مع ما تشهده من قتال يومي وانعدام
في السلع الاساسيه وتحول الصراع في بعض
المناطق بهذا الاقليم الى صراع الكل ضد
الكل مما خلف جرائم كثيره جدا وتعتبر
كارثيه بالنسبه للانسان الان المويه
الواحد يمشي بيت في او يجيب صف من الصباح
لحد الازر عشان يجيب برميل بداموال وينتهي
اليوم الثاني يعني معاناه لدرجه اكثر من
كده وبعدين
الماكل والمشرب في ناس كثير هيكون خارج
اليوم باليوم في السوق والاسواق هما شغاله
والله الاسعار دي مبالغه فيها يعني اسعار
يوميا يعني في اليوم ممكن يزيد حاجه
بمرتين عندك مساله جاز الجاز اول امس ب
350 البرميل
يعني الفتره السبعه هي لما بقينا الفتره
النسائيه بيجوارب مئه الصباح ب 500
يعني شوف اسعار غيالي كما امتدت رقعه
الصراع لتشمل مناطق من جنوب دارفور وايضا
محليات تتبع لشمال دارفور من ضمنها محليه
كتم الصراع ايضا اثر على حركه الطرق بين
المدن المختلفه هنا في اقليم دارفور كما
انه ساهم مساهمه كبيره في عدم ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه من بورسودان الى
دارفور صالح ابو علامه في قناته العربيه
والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان
تفتتح اليوم في الرياضه السفاره الايرانيه
بحضور ممثلين عن وزرتي الخارجيه السعوديه
والايرانيه الافتتاح ياتي بعد ثلاثه اشهر
من توقيع التفاهمات السعوديه الايرانيه
الاستئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بينهما
برعايه صينيه
هكذا مصدر امني مصري مسؤول في تصريحات
للعربيه ان بيان تنظيم داعش الذي اعلن فيه
مسؤوليته عن حادث الحدود بين مصر واسرائيل
غير صحيح واضاف المصدر ان البيان هو
محاوله لاثبات ان داعش موجود في سيناء
وهذا غير صحيح حيث انه تم القضاء على
الارهاب بنسبه تجاوزت خمسه وتسعين بالمئه
وتتم عمليات التمشيط والتطهير وشدد المصدر
الامني للعربي على ان التسلل اي عناصر
ارهابيه الى الحدود مع اسرائيل صعب للغايه
مؤكدا ان نقاط الحدوديه مؤمنه بشكل كامل
بدوريات مشتركه من الجيش والشرطه
شهد مركز التسويه في درعا بجنوب سوريا شهد
اقبالا من قبل المتخلفين عن اداء الخدمه
العسكريه وكذلك المطلوبين امنيا خلال
السنوات الاخيره بهدف تسويه اوضاعهم
خلال يومين فقط توجه نحو الفي شخص الى
مركز قصر الحوريات بدرعه متقدمين بطلب شطب
اسمائهم من الملاحقات القانونيه والامنيه
طامحين الى استصدار وثائق واوراق شخصيه
لممارسه حياتهم بشكل طبيعي النائب عن
محافظه درعا احمد السويدان يرى ان التسويه
فرصه لكل من اعاقه الظروف تسويه اوضاعه
سابقا سواء كان متخلفا عن الخدمتين
الالزاميه والاحتياطيه ام فارا من الجيش
ما هي فرصه للشبان اللي ما قدروا يعملوا
تسويه
سابقه وشايفين الاقبال كبير جدا جدا
والتسويه هي اجراءاتها مبسطه جدا اللجنه
الامنيه في محافظه درعا بصت كل الاجراءات
وبسبب الازدهام الشديد والاقبال الشديد
على هذه التسويه
ممكن تتمدد لبعد يوم الخميس
ويفتحوا مركز ثانيه وتهدف التسويات الى
منح المتخلفين عن الخدمه العسكريه فرصه
العوده الى مواقعهم السابقه وانهاء التوتر
السائد في محافظه درعا جنوبي سوريا والتي
اندلعت فيها شعله المظاهرات المعارضه منذ
اكثر من 12 عاما واليوم صار فيه هل مبادره
الطيبه واني جاي وجاي بابني وهذا ابني معي
ابني من مطار حلب بالامن الجوي
وبيرجع لقطعته وبده الوطن واحنا ابناء
الوطن ويرجح مسؤولون سوريون تمديد استقبال
الطلبات لايام اخرى مع احتماليه فتح مركز
اخر بسبب الاقبال الشديد للراغبين في
التسويه نور الحصني العربيه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
شركه ابل تعلن عن نظاره ذكيه تمزج بسلاسه
بين العالم الواقعي والعالم الافتراضي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اليوم الرابع عشر من
الاضرابات العامه في فرنسا ضد قانون
التقاعد انطلقت المظاهرات الرئيسيه في
باريس حيث بدات التجمعات في ساحه قريبه من
الجمعيه الوطنيه وقد اعنت السلطات
الفرنسيه عن نشر ما لا يقل عن احد عشر الف
عنصر من قوات الشرطه والدرك لتامين
التظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي ستنطلق في
جميع انحاء البلاد بدعوه من الاتحاد
النقابي ضد قانوني اصلاح نظام التقاعد
الذي اثار في الفتره الماضيه موجه غضب
عارمه
اعلنت شركه ابل في مؤتمرها العالمي السنوي
للمطورين عن جهاز جديد طال انتظاره
ابل
وهي عباره عن نظاره ذكيه مزوده بسماعات
تمزج بسلاسه بين العالم الواقعي والعالم
الافتراضي وفق ما ذكره مدير الشركه
التنفيذي تيم كوك
وذلك بتصميم يختلف عن الاجهزه المشابهه
المطروحه في السوق وبحسب كوك يسمح الجهاز
الجديد للمستخدمين بان يروا ويسمعوا
ويتفاعلوا مع المحتوى الافتراضي كما لو
انهم يرونه في الواقع حولهم ويتم التحكم
بالجهاز باستخدام اليدين والعينين والصوت
معا
وتصمد بطاريه الجهاز الجديد مده ساعتين
وسيكون متوفرا العمل مقبل في الولايات
المتحده بسعر ثلاثه الاف واربعمائه وتسعه
وتسعين دولارا
ويعتبر سعره اعلى بكثير من اجهزه مشاهده
الواقع الافتراضي المتوفره في الاسواق
حاليا
[موسيقى]
في حدث سيكون الاول منذ 130 عاما لفرد
رفيع المستوى من الاسره المالكه لبريطانيه
ادلى الامير هاري اليوم بشهادته امام
المحكمه التي تنظر في دعوه رفعها ضد اعده
صحف من بينها صحيفه الدين مرر البريطانيه
قال انها تسللت الى فتره مراهقته بشكل غير
قانوني
حيث ستبحث المحكمه 33 قصه خبريه من اصل
147 في قضيه انتهاك الصحافه لخصوص لخصوصيه
الامير الشام وذلك بعد تقديم دوق ادعاءات
عده لجمع هذه الصحف اخبارا عن مراهقته
بطرق غير قانونيه بين عامي
1996 و2010
الخامسه من العربيه انتهت اعزائي
المشاهدين اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات